but i don't think i'm mean yes you are i
no i'm not you are no i'm not
you're no stranger
no spoilers are stupid
no spoilers you're stupid and you can
edit this out if we need to but we're
not and i quote how he said to one
contestant
do you know lindsay sterling and the
person lit up and was like of course i
love her and he literally looked him in
the eyes and said i imagine you're what
her nightmares look like no
why did you say that that's so mean
you are you've gotten meaner here's what
i've got here's what i've gotten i won't
cut that out
here's what i've gotten like brutally
honest it was really hard for me
at the beginning to be a judge and i'll
tell you what was hard first and
foremost like you said we're both
performers we've been in front of the
audience so i kind of know what it feels
like and i had that empathy
the next thing was if i legitimately if
something is so
so like are you kidding me
are you kidding me it was really hard
for me to say that because
um when we started on america's got
talent we used to travel yeah and so i'd
be in dallas and this person would be at
dallas's own so and so so if you see
anything that wasn't positive you get
booed and i wasn't used to i wanted the
audience to like me right and they like
when you go you are going all the way
they'll always applaud and then it was
about and then i thought and then i
started watching and i said you know
most people people are going to hate me
for being honest but most i gotta say
what i'm thinking
and i think i do something i i think
it's my obligation and i think i'm being
paid for being honest and i do remember
that person and i thought that that
person was kidding i thought that that
would that was just come on come on
i don't think they were oh
you also like the ridiculous acts like
you will put there's a there's a thin
line between ridiculous and just what
what the [ __ ] are you doing do you know
what i love sitting beside howie the
most is when a stand-up comic comes out
howie
lights up he's whispering oh this is
great this is hard like it's he's
because i think we're underappreciated i
think i think you will never say
anything bad and be mean no because i
think being able to show up and stand on
that spot and
here's the thing
if you go to an amateur night at any
comedy club you will see people say
sometimes it's cringe-worthy
nobody is there under their own fruition
somebody is there because one person at
a dinner or something says you're so
funny you should be a comedian
the luck is
that what i do
more than just uncle nathan a whole room
liked it like think about how i made a i
made a living pulling a [ __ ] rubber
glove on my head
i mean most people go well that's not an
act that's nothing and i just so happens
that whatever my sense of humor was and
it's
you know kind of narrow
a larger group of people liked it i've
told the story ad nauseam when i sold
out i sold up tonight he played with me
we did two sold out shows at radio city
musical and between the two shows we
were up in the dressing room you were
there lou was there he saved his
underpants and framed them from that
night didn't you yeah i did that's
amazing he did
because they didn't have any pictures so
dolly has the underpants
from that's incredible it is so but
seven thousand people were walking out
onto sixth or seventh avenue wherever
that is seven thousand people were
walking in there's fourteen thousand
people in the street they had stanchions
and cops my wife is standing there your
mom and she goes what this is all for
you what are you thinking and i'm
thinking in this
city of ten million
nine million eight hundred and
eighty-six thousand people don't give a
[ __ ] i'm here
so the point is if you sit but it is
that's the truth and
as many people like so when if i'm
seeing somebody even if they're terrible
the fact that you're willing to go out
there that's a verbal tightrope a
personal tightrope
just to show up not singing a cover of
somebody else's song
not doing a magic trick that you bought
you know and you paid somebody to show
you how to do it and it's a trick
not
having a troop of people that are moving
like you just to go out there and
hopefully that people hook onto your
words
to me is amazing that you're willing to
show up no i agree i totally agree it's
just such a joy sitting beside you
because you turn into a happy little
child it's incredible because everything
i've ever been punished for expelled for
hit for is what i get paid for today and
i did not chase this uh career it found
me and i needed it and it is my survival
so seeing i have an appreciat an added
appreciation for other people that are
willing to try it but some people
shouldn't be doing it but and they
should make that decision after they do
it a couple of times you know they need
to make that decision they'll make that
decision after you judge them
i'm sure of it i'm very when i tell them
you are lindsay sterling's worst
nightmare literally go home in his to
his eyes that's so sad
they used to say simon was the meanest
or harshest and now they all say you are
but i respect that i do yeah i respect
that as someone that sat next to you and
had a hard time always being honest and
i got better at it as we went yeah but i
it's that in itself is a talent to be
like hey i don't care if the audience
boosts me this is how i feel and i'm
going to stand up for how i feel the
truth is that you got it listen you
can't give people blind optimism in the
sense that they're going to humiliate
themselves they're not going to make any
you know if anything at a at that point
in my career i would have loved to hear
how can i make this better how what
should i do maybe i need to go in
another direction maybe this is why this
isn't good and i want to try something
else i don't think we need to be
oblivious so and they know you'd show up
knowing you're going to be judged
you know what's your next question
[Music]
you